>>> FORMERMA AND O SHOICAL A
ON THEE TO FIGHT
THRUS.
THE FORMER PREDE E, PROFOUND DEF
GRLL OUR HEALTH PRONALS AND EVE
BE ON THE FRONT
PAWHILE.
EVER BEHAVIOR OWN SACRIFICEOTHR
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS RPOSF ABOUT
HIMSELF FROMHE
HE'S TREATG CORONAVIRUSGS THEMOR
DOCTOR, T SO MUCHINRE ON MATERN
WHO ICHSEE.
WHAT'S L LNOW?
>> WELL,A NEWORMAL
AVE THE B I
ULL NIGHT A'M
FEEDING HER EVERY TWO
CH MYK ANDIR GRADER,G
TO D MY
HUSBISLF IN A
SEPARATEOUUSCY DOCTOR,
IN A GARAGE TORO
FAMILY.THATN A DIFFICULT
DEONSP S
PRECIOUS ANGEL, ONLY WEEKS
OLD, NOT TO MENTIONWO
MUNCHKINS.
>> IT WASCULT
H AND IRE
PR FORTE
A PLACE INUR HOUSE WHE ANDEPARAI
DY HAS
AT.LLUB  CING IIMPORTANT.
HEALTH CARE WORKECOEA PARTICITE
IN THAT BECAUSE THEY' OCOURSE G
>> THEY'RE DNG THEF HEENOUMASKS
UIPMENT?
S.  I
TO LEAVE FOOD
OF HIS DOOR A SIETHAT HE NEED.
>>'T MEAN THAT, SLYOF HIM, B ATT
PA B I THINK THAT A RISK
WE CLDE ISSUES AT
I THINK IT'SNT SME,
REDUCE THEPREAD THI
>> YOU DESCRIBED I AS ICULFPLE
FOLLOWING SOCIAL DING
RECOMMENDAS US HUSBAND AR
FALYROUGH.WE'VE SEEN THESEORRIF
HFI
PEOPLESPREAK I
FLOR A
NOTHING'S GOING S AT
DISNEY WORLD,S'S YOUR PEOPLE NI
SOCIAL DISTANCGE?
>> I MEANKOUGHME, IMAGINED MY
LEAVE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER PE SU
ANTHAT, YOU KNOW A TOGETHER.THL
E FLA CU
D H RED I THINK B WE CAN
REALLY SUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE LIK M G
SACR TO L
TO PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE AND TO
STAY HOME.
THAT
SOMEONE LIKE ME
TO SEEN P OVER THEKEERY
QUARTERS.
IT'S HAR BECAUSE OF
THATSACRIFICE.
NOW HOW LONG THIOU GOST
EFFICULT JO
THOUTBREAK W
ESILIE AND
WED TO DO WHAT WE  GIVEN
THAT THIS ON FOROME, TO DO O TO
FIRST SPONDERS, ANDISTENO LTH G
STAY HOME